bonjour à tous vous êtes sur lcp et
public sénat c'est l'heure de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de l'actualité
parlementaire et politique qui s'est
passé beaucoup de choses cette semaine
énormément au jour katia et on va en
parler d'abord les titres l'épreuve de
force pour faire passer la loi macron
l'article 49 3 de la constitution s'est
appliqué la procédure permette de faire
adopter un texte sans vote
en engageant la responsabilité du
gouvernement la droite a déposé une
motion de surprise rejeté sans surprise
des députés du front de gauche ont voté
pour avec l'ump et la plupart des
députés centristes
la discussion de cette loi maquereau a
révélé des fractures au sein de la
majorité frondeurs d'un côté loyaliste
de l'autre chacun campe sur ses
positions affrontement possible autre de
gauche à quatre voies du congrès
socialiste
et puis la question sensible de la fin
de vie revient dans le débat promesse de
campagne de françois hollande un nouveau
texte doit arriver à l'assemblée les
diverses propositions loire puis député
ps alain claeys c'est son collègue ump
jean leonetti le texte divise à droite
mais aussi à gauche et pour commenter
toute cette semaine politique très
chargée dans votre corps bonjour thierry
mandon bonjour secrétaire d'état chargé
de la réforme de taille la
simplification on va évidemment déroulé
tout le fil de cette actualité vous
allez commenter longuement tout ce qui
s'est passé à l'assemblée nationale est
bien évidemment ailleurs on va d'abord
écouter c'est le principe de cette
émission quelques parlementaires qui
vont dresser votre portrait puis vous
réagirez bien sûr juste après je trouve
qu'il a une tâche extrêmement difficile
qui consiste dans le fait de trouver des
gisements simplification dans
l'entrelacs de nos textes législatifs
mais par ailleurs voilà c'est un un
membre du gouvernement qui travaille
qu'à un gros boulot il faut souhaiter
qu'il réussisse dans l'intérêt de la
france quand il a été chargé d'un
travail sur la simplification
je les rencontre et à ce moment là parce
que moi j'ai travaillé beaucoup
là-dessus en tant que fonctionnaire à la
aux ministères de bercy a pendant une
dizaine d'années donc je lui dis battait
chargé de ça c'est formidable on va
échanger
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un très réceptif de
très sympa en plus il est entré au
gouvernement après la 14 c'est d'être
socialiste parce que je reconnais qu'il
est buecher qui connaît bien ses
dossiers et qu'il n'est pas arrogant
ce qui pour un certain nombre de la
majorité présidentielle n'est pas un
défaut parce que c'est assez rare au
fond ce qui me plaît chez thierry c'est
d'être dans la réalité concrète de ce
qui fait avancer le pays et dans ce
travail de simplification il ya
énormément à faire avec à chaque fois
des enjeux politiques à apporter on l'a
vu d'ailleurs sur certaines des
dispositions qu'on a noté qu on a
discuté dans le cadre du projet de loi
sur la croissance et l'activité
ça a l'air plutôt sympathique dans
l'ensemble il ya quelque chose qui est
une petite musique qui ressort c'est que
réformer c'est la très très très
compliqué voire mis sur la possible
nouvelle simplifier je crois qu'il ya
pas plus difficile que simplifier c'est
à la fois indispensable mais sait on est
dans le juridisme on est dans l'autre en
polo j parce que le nombre de règles
existant dans ce pays c'est le produit
de l'histoire
on est donc dans le coeur même de la
fabrique de la démocratie et les
dysfonctionnements de la fabriquer vos
propres et les blocages des bloqueurs et
les blocages partout partout il ya des
blocages dans l'administration il ya
parfois des blocages politiques
bien que ce travail soit assez
consensuel d'ailleurs le reportage le
monde mais votre vous êtes un peu le
monsieur choc de simplification du
gouvernement est ce que vous avez des
annonces concrètes des choses tangibles
à nous à nous dire sur cette salle en
question qu'est ce qui a nui non je vous
donnais les prochaines pistes de travail
de deux ou trois très très importante
mais d'abord il n'y a pas d'annoncés ya
jamais de lens puisque eu la première
méthode qu'on arrêtait ses du plan
d'action car chaque fois qu on dit
quelque chose on donne un délai
généralement de moins de six mois dans
lequel ces sera réalisé et on a un
système d'évaluation indépendant sur le
concret on est en train de préparer une
nouvelle livraison de mesures de
simplification pour les entreprises y
aura deux très gros morceau premier
morceau les relations entre l'urssaf et
les pme pmi
tous les profs de contentieux qu'il ya
comme on peut alléger sa comment on peut
simplifier sa meute des relations
beaucoup plus confiante entre l'urssaf
et les pme pmi et deuxième gros morceau
le rsi le régime social des indépendants
6 millions de personnes en france où il
ya des problèmes en pagaille et qu'on va
essayer de régler chaque fois ça c'est
vraiment comme ça ça c'est pour le mois
d'avril
enfin tout cas la première mesure les
premières mesures les premières mesures
du plan d'action en avril deuxième chose
très très très importante et
probablement en avril nous aurons la
participation notre réunion de
simplification de monsieur timmerman ce
qu'est le premier vice président de la
commission européenne puisque nous nous
attaquons désormais à la simplification
des directives européennes entre les pme
et le rock
tous domaines et là il ya énormément à
faire c'est très important comme
chantier j'ai vu monsieur timmerman
cette semaine mardi matin il m'a dit que
la position que la france a d'ailleur
commune avec la position allemande
pourrait être la pression pour qu'on va
simplifier les relations des petites et
moyennes entreprises avec l'europe ce
qui était une demande de toutes les
chefs d'entreprise exactement ça va me
mettre encore très très bien puisqu'il
n'y aura plus aucune disposition de
directive européenne qui concerne les
pme pmi qui ne sera pas testé sur des
pme/pmi avant que d'être voilà bonne ont
rejoint par un président très pressés
des gros sujets sains tension là on est
sur plusieurs millions dans ces séries
la nesque aussi c'est l'impression que
c'était les 12 oui c'est les deux je
suis passé douze travaux d'hercule ccc
sisyphe aussi parfois c est vous êtes
tous vous allez souvent et on continue à
pousser et en plus on est heureux de le
faire et il ya un symbole quand même
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'ena vous êtes
en charge aussi de réformer c'est
l'école nationale la haute
administration les énarques comme on les
appelle
qu'est-ce que ça devient l'ena on
supprime narainen ces mêmes sabah plus
notre local je pense que le problème de
notre administration de notre fonction
publique j'allais dire de notre haute
fonction publique c'est qu'elle est trop
haute et pas assez managériale or l'état
la puissance publique a maintenant
besoin de gens qui pilote le changement
des organisations publiques des
administrations qui soient des leaders
d'équipés qui soient des animaux
naissent l'entreprise ce qu'ils
connaissent l'entreprise qui connaît ces
ressources là elle sent que c'est pas
des profils classiques comme ont formé
avant les hauts fonctionnaires comme des
gens très intelligente très brillant
mais finalement qui étaient pas des
chefs d'equipe il faut qu'on change ap
le contenu des formations pour par des
gens qui soient plus des moteurs du
changement dans les métropoles du
terrain surtout le terrain est tout
autre et on revient sur une semaine est
une semaine marquée par le choc des
attentats qui ont frappé le danemark ce
lundi
lundi l'europe se réveille donc sous le
choc après deux fusillades à copenhague
contre un centre culturel et près de la
grande synagogue de la capitale danoise
deux morts et cinq blessés le tueur un
danois de 22 ans qui s'était radicalisé
a été abattu en france manuel valls est
revenu sur ces événements avec des mots
chocs
invité lundi matin de rtl écoutez je
pense qu'il faut désormais une rupture
il faut que l'islam de france assume
prennent totalement ses responsabilités
c'est ce que demandent d'ailleurs
l'immense majorité de nos compatriotes
musulmans qui n'en peuvent plus et eux
aussi d'être non seulement la cible
d'attaqués qui sont elles mêmes le
supportable mais d'être confondus avec
cette terreur pour combattre cette
islamofascisme puisque c'est ainsi qu'il
faut le nommer l'unité doit être notre
force je le rappelais il nous faut ni cd
ni à la peur ni à la division le terme
islamo fascisme a fait beaucoup parler
ça a choqué une partie de la communauté
musulmane vous comprenez ça puisse
choquer d'utiliser ce terme assez
controversé je partage totalement une
partie 2 de jean kidder se réclament de
l'islam et n'ont plus grand chose à voir
avec ce qu'est l'islam se comporte de
manière trop totalement totalitaire et
cette branche là 7 c'est cette
radicalité de la qui se revendiquent de
l'écu cela même si à mon avis elle n'a
pas grand chose à voir avec lui nuit à
l'ensemble de la religion donc les
musulmans de france doivent eux aussi
participer de cette dénonciation et ne
pas reconnaître comme des leurs ces gens
qui commettent ces années sombres ou
islamo fascistes c'est vrai qu'on avait
tendance à l'entendre à droite peut-être
me voir extrême droite on a l'impression
qu'à gauche il ya une sorte de tabou qui
a été levée avec ce genre d'expressions
qui était employé surtout par manuel
valls fall dira peut-être mais il a
raison il a raison de dire que
il ya une radicalisation qui n'a plus
rien à voir avec la religion musulmane
et que c'est en séries en bien ces deux
catégories de de croyance que finalement
on protège ceux qui pratiquent un islam
de dire les choses c'est la méthode de
manuel valls est la méthode s'est nommé
totalement je pense que toute la semaine
dernière nous avons un problème dans le
pays qui est un déni de réalité
c'est à dire qu'il ya des choses qu'on
veut pas voir et même quand on les voit
dont on ne veut pas parler
donc je pense que les pathologies les
maladies profonde de la société
française aujourd'hui sont
principalement liées à cette volonté
soit de ne pas voir soit quant aux voix
de deux balles et tourner la tête
il faut recréer du débat public sur les
problèmes qui concernent les gens sur
les craintes qu'ont les français etc et
c'est ça que fait en sa manière de
manuel valls
et c'est le solde non je pense que le
présent votre camp qui est aussi sur
cette fusion les choses les mémés manuel
valls a un talent pour la formule
synthétique qui résume pierre la parade
aujourd'hui l'islam fasciste c'est un
apport à la vie politique cette façon
qu'il a de caractériser les je vois pas
ce mardi ça y est cette jolie paloma
kron le gouvernement il n'a pas voulu
prendre de risque avec cette loi macro
et ne sera pas soumise au vote des
députés le premier ministre a préféré
utiliser une arme institutionnels
qu'elle a le droit c'est le 49-3
évidemment ce recours n'a pas déclenché
que d enthousiasme à gauche comme à
droite on va d'abord écouter le point et
demi ça plus on fera des réactions juste
après le conseil des ministres qui s'est
réuni aujourd'hui sous la présidence du
chef de l'état à 14h30 m'a autorisé à
engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement sur le projet de loi
croissance et activités conformément à
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la constitution
une majorité existe vraisemblablement
sur ce texte
mais
elle est incertaine des l'orgue et c'est
ma responsabilité je le prendrai aucun
risque je le prendrai pas la
responsabilité du risque d'un rejet d'un
tel projet que je considère comme
essentiel pour notre économie
comment le gouvernement en est il venu à
décider ce recours aux 49 3 le vote
était prévu mardi vers 16h mais le matin
même tout s'est accéléré en quelques
heures récit d'une folle journée avec l
amont d'un gars à mardi matin devant les
députés ps le premier ministre prévient
à ce stade le texte ne passe pas dans
ces conditions le premier ministre chef
de la majorité en appelle à la
responsabilité de son camp de ses
propres troupes
à ce moment difficile de savoir s'il
s'agit d'une réelle inquiétude ou d'une
volonté de mettre la pression sur les
frondeurs un peu avant 14h les choses
s'accélèrent un conseil des ministres
exceptionnel est convoqué à l'elysée la
possibilité de l'utilisation du 49-3 est
évoqué
le premier ministre obtient
l'autorisation de principe de son
gouvernement
un peu plus tard dans l'hémicycle manuel
valls sème le trouble
on comprend tour à tour qu'il est prête
à engager la responsabilité de son
gouvernement
moi la seule chose que je vous dis et
vous le verrez dans quelques minutes
c'est que le gouvernement fera tout pour
que cette loi passe parce que ces lois
elle est utile pour le pays et pour la
france puis il semble croire en un
ultime sursaut de sa majorité
à ce stade je veux le dire encore une
fois je pense que si chacun se ressaisit
si chacun prend bien conscience qui se
joue quelque chose d'important et nous
sommes à un moment de vérité
ce texte peut passer dans cet hémicycle
en réalité le premier ministre et son
ministre des relations parlement essaye
encore de rallier de précieux votes et
se livre à une comptabilité précise ça
ne suffit pas s'inquiète jean marie le
guen
voter c'est prendre le risque de voir la
loi rejeter alors le premier ministre
conclut donc tu n'es pas sûr on va
pouvoir engager tout de suite
à 16h15 manuel valls échange un dernier
coup de fil avec françois hollande et
obtient le feu vert du président de la
république pour engager la
responsabilité de son gouvernement
voilà alors plus de 190 heures de débat
une commission spéciale un très bon
travail parlementaire de l'avis de tous
ceux qui ont travaillé sur ce texte on a
envie de dire tout ça pour ça pour en
arriver à l'utilisation du 49 3 est ce
que vous n'avez pas le sentiment thierry
mandon que le débat parlementaire a été
un peu confisqués si c'est cet épisode
est un triste épisode pour la vie
politique
puisqu'en fait il ya eu 2 c'est une
pièce en deux actes il ya un premier
acte est magnifique c'est une invention
dans la vème république d'une façon de
faire la loi nouvelle c'est que emmanuel
macron à piloter avec des amendements
mille amendements votés sur tous les
bancs accepter surtout les bandes comme
vous l'avez dit près de 200 heures de
séances fait un travail de coproduction
législative qui honore l'exécutif et le
législatif sur tous les bancs et la voix
face termine et tous les articles
ça c'est le plus important pour
comprendre la signification voter on dit
c'est mona bras et érotisme tous les
articles
un parent ont tous été votée ça ça
s'arrête le dimanche à 6 heures du matin
et puis patatras qu entre le dimanche
après midi et lundi on découvre qu'il ya
des gens qui on n'avait jamais vu ou
quasiment rien qui avait même pas
participé au débat parlementaire ou
appel qui se dit mais nous on sera
content quoi qu'il arrive je n'aime pas
les gens vous disent certains c'est à
quelqu'un en particulier à gauche à
droite parce que se balade on parle
frondeur chez nous mais c'est assez vrai
rond on parle des verts c'est même mieux
madame duflot avait expliqué quelques
voterait pas le texte
alors qu'il n'était même pas encore
inscrit à l'assemblée dit que c'est
irresponsable mais je dis pas que c'est
de la vieille politique c'est de la
vieille politique le regard des dix
courses à se caser l'histoire d'une
nouvelle façon de faire de la politique
on a droit ne pas être d'accord mais on
participe pas au débat et ont dit aux
débats on n'est pas d'accord mais quand
vous avez finalement un texte est adopté
article par article puis que d'un seul
coup dégâts débarque isabeau n'en a
absolument pas de ça excusez moi c'est
le choc de nouvelles méthodes et de
vieilles méthodes
et pour une fois mais probablement une
des dernières fois c'est la vieille
politique qui l'a emporté vous verrez on
pensera deux victimes dans tout ça
premièrement hélas pas besoin de ça la
scène politique dans son ensemble parce
que le spectacle pitoyable mais 2 a
laissé des traces
ça va laisser des traces à gauche à
droite partout mais deuxièmement ce qu
ont participé à cette vieille politique
qui incarne ces délits politiques qui
incarne l'incapacité à part à prendre en
compte la qualité du travail législatif
cela aussi vous verrez qui le permet
vous dit rien parce que la vision est
celle gauche à droite il ya tout le
monde est au clair vous pensez à qui
parce que là aussi quand même une bonne
partie de votre camp mais je bats une
quarantaine de députés je vais pas vous
dire qu'on trouve fantastique la
position compris les entre guillemets
frondeurs voilà à la limite ils sont
très regardants au final mais évidemment
pourquoi parce que les français veulent
des partis politiques qui assume
clairement loyalement la responsabilité
de la direction du local de son noyau et
ce qui s'est joué notamment dans notre
camp c'est une rupture avec la culture
de gouvernement
on peut n'être pas d'accord y compris
avec son propre gouvernement et aucun
problème encore que il n'y a pas de
problème on s'abstient on le fait à
babouri on se défend ses positions et
puis on dit bon la majorité a tranché
très bien aller voter contre
donc voté son propre gouvernement
prendre le risque de faire tomber son
gouvernement l'obliger à passer par 43
ça manque un peu d'esprit de
responsabilité on va revenir a
évidemment sur ces frondeurs il ya eu
des réactions à gauche à droite on va
les entendre
j'ai juste après ils ont du mal à cacher
leur satisfaction dans l'hémicycle mais
aussi dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
nationale
le voit que les députés frondeurs ont
réussi leur pari poussé le gouvernement
à utiliser larmes du 49 3 moi je n'ai
pas l'intention d'affaiblir le
gouvernement
je pense que le gouvernement doit se
ressaisir il on a tout à fait les moyens
parce que c'est aussi un peu l'échec
d'une méthode qui consiste à vouloir
toujours passer en force sans estimé
nécessaire la discussion et dialogue
politique avec la partie de sa majorité
qui n'adhèrent pas à l'orientation
sociale libérale bombe à un moment donné
ça se traduit par un défaut de majorité
c'était prévisible
une ligne de fracture au sein du parti
socialiste entre la gauche et les
soutiens du gouvernement autour de la
loi macron ce devait être la grande
réforme de la seconde partie du
quinquennat de françois hollande
mais la majorité socialiste s'est
largement divisés certains proches de
l'exécutif ne cachent pas leur amertume
c'est désespérant qu'il y en ait qui ne
sont pas ce que c'est qu'un gouvernement
qu'il faut être derrière et qui a des
moments où on se serre les coudes
sinon on meurt tous certain nombre de
membres du parti socialiste avec à leur
tête benoît hamon ont préféré la
préparation du congrès du parti
socialiste à l'intérêt de la france à
l'intérêt de la nation à l'intérêt de
l'état face à des socialistes qui se
déchire la droite elle ironise elle
parle des chefs politiques et d'aveu de
faiblesse comme aveu terrible
impuissance
voilà un gouvernement qui non seulement
qu'on va pas les français mais qui n'est
même plus capable de tenir sa majorité
ça peut pas continuer une première
depuis le début de la législature le
front gauche s'associera la droite et
votre à la censure contre manuel valls
ils dénoncent un passage en force du
gouvernement
terre'blanche en projet un peu vos
propos qui étaient là juste à l'instant
vous parlez de thenon de vieilles
politiques et on est d'accord
qu'est ce qu'on fait de ses ténors de la
vie politique on va les appeler les
frondeurs pour faire assez large chasse
aux sorcières on les punit non non je
pense que la bonne réponse
si on croit aux textes qu'on a fait
adopter par le 49 3 et j'y crois c'est
d'abord de faire en sorte qu'il
s'applique le plus vite possible qu'on
invente une sorte de 49,3 de
l'application du texte pour que nous
puissions apporter la preuve
et elle sera apportée que les
dispositions qui ont été votées adopter
bientôt par le sénat hier par
l'assemblée nationale se créent de
l'emploi qu'elles sont utiles à
l'économie et qu'elle n'enlève aucun
droit scénario promet aux fans si si je
vous dis que il faut leur montrer à tous
ceux qui n'ont pas vu de ce thème leur
montrer la preuve qu'ils se trompent
je suis désolé s'appelle ça s'appellera
une défaite politique
ils ont besoin de cette défaite
politique donc par la persuasion pas par
la preuve pas par la preuve parce que la
politique ont fait pas des choses pour
se disputer comme ça à longueur de
journée on fait des choses pour les
français et ce texte on l'a fait voter
parce qu'on pense à l'abri des belles à
créer de l'emploi
le plus rapidement possible le plus vite
possible aussi avant la fin d'année oui
c'est possible il faut et on y travaille
faut que les décrets soient préparés en
même temps que l'adoption du texte de
loi pour que dès que le texte de loi est
votée définitivement les décrets
s'appliquent et il faut que les
premières mesures soit en actions maman
même l'avait quand même que il ya
l'étape du sénat c'est une chose
il y aura ensuite une nouvelle étape à
l'assemblée nationale vous la craignais
cette deuxième étape nous toute façon
maintenant et le 49-3 est attaché à ce
texte donc dossevi il y aura 49 3 pour
le double j'en sais rien en retour est
en tout cas c'est tout à fait possible
puisque celle ci est juridiquement
maintenant c'est possible donc c'est pas
prêt non mais je réponds je vous réponde
franchement de cession premièrement la
preuve
deuxièmement est ce que il faut des
sanctions c'est ça votre question
moi je crois pas qu'il faille poser le
problème dans ces termes
ce qui est sûr c'est que cette situation
n'est pas tenable et il est sûr que ceux
qui persistent dans la fronde contre le
gouvernement à qui finalement sont pas
d'accord dans nos rangs avec le
gouvernement après tous légitimement
considérer qu'ils ont raison mais ils
peuvent pas représenter le parti
socialiste
donc ils peuvent ils peuvent être
socialiste mais peuvent pas avoir des
responsabilités vous avez été pas de
parole pour parler de course et c'est
vous les appelez à former notre groupe
avec leur nom pour du tout ils peuvent
rester dans le parti c'est pas le
problème est simplement ils peuvent
savoir être ils peuvent pas avoir des
responsabilités
évidemment fait sanctionner personne ne
comprend rien si vous avez des
responsables socialistes ces bonnes mais
c'est pas des sanctions c'est que à
terme c'est pas durable et ceux qui
s'opposent à la politique du
gouvernement peuvent pas incarner la
politique de gouvernement parmi leurs
délires si quelqu'un partie-là gros qui
dit on n'a pas d'eau n'a pas dit on va
discuter qu'est-ce que vous ne leur avez
complètement raison il n'y a pas de
dialogue il ya simplement deux mille
amendements qui ont été adoptées il ya
cinq semaines de débats ça s'est jamais
vu franchement la théorie du passage en
force sur ce texte c'est proche de la
farce
cc et canto à la qualification de
libéral de ce texte qui est donnée
aspect c'est une erreur il ya au moins
autant de dispositions qui régule qui
organise qui encadrent qui créent les
droits pour les salariés qui à
disposition qui ouvre des espaces de
liberté pour les entreprises donc c'est
pas un texte social libéral et c'est
surtout pas des texans passage en force
après deux ans on peut s'opposer y
compris dans nos l'art la politique du
gouvernement
il faut l'assumer sans omettre de
d'autocollants représentant la
discussion de cette loi maquereau a mis
en lumière les divisions au sein de la
gauche française on en parlait du parti
socialiste rend pas
yat-il d'un côté des sociaux-libéraux de
l'autre des frondeurs des positions
irréconciliables deux idéologies récit
de jean baptiste daoulas des frondeurs
dans la ligne de mire de leurs camarades
du ps à l'assemblée
les mots sont durs contre ceux qui ont
forcé manuel valls a dégainé le 49-3 ça
je crois que c'est une véritable
faillite dans le travail parlementaire
quand le dogmatisme l'emportent sur la
volonté de régler les difficultés au
service des français
quand la préparation d'un congrès
l'emportent sur la volonté de légiférer
au bénéfice de l'intérêt général des
frondeurs accusé d'être dans la posture
d'instrumentaliser la loi macron pour
marquer des points
à quelques mois du congrès du ps la
question du congrès du parti socialiste
n'est pas au coeur de nos préoccupations
c'est une vision médiocre de ce que nous
sommes que deux que de co2 que d'avancer
cette idée là nous avons des convictions
et nous les défendons autre problème
celui du fonctionnement interne du
groupe ps à l'assemblée
le dialogue entre députés est en panne
certains ont refusé de donner leurs
intentions de vote sur la loi macron au
point que le gouvernement a été
incapable de faire un pointage précis
dans le collimateur notamment valérie
rabault rapporteur général du budget
compte une rapporteur général du budget
ne veut même pas dire son choix de vote
voilà on est dans le surréalisme qu'au
total j'aime beaucoup dali mais en
peinture pas en politique
donc on fait ses choix tant qu' on les
assume on les assume devant ses
camarades comme philippe doucet beaucoup
de députés demandent des sanctions pour
les frondeurs en les privant de toute
responsabilité à l'assemblée alors vous
dites vous avez dit à l'instant que ce
n'était la situation n'était pas tenable
notamment avec ces frondeurs est ce que
pour vous bruno le roux qui est
j'avais des députés socialistes à
l'assemblée tient suffisamment bien
c'est trop con avec à droite la
discipline de vote quand même bien
fonctionné oui enfin là fonctionner
quand même un certain nombre de députés
ump qu elle s apprêtait à voter le texte
s'il avait dit m
big man donc chacun à ses preuves et je
veux dire tant mieux parce que le débat
politique où c'est vraiment militaire la
gauche et pour la droite et contre la
droite et pour la gauche et qu'on se
retire ses troupes
oui les tient de les frondeurs faut
rappeler que c'est à peu près 10% du
groupe et 90% du groupe qui n'a pas de
problème certes besoin de capacité de
d'expression est le prolongement il
suscite l'intérêt des médias et c'est
comme ça mais oui il tient il tient ses
troupes week-end ses troupes en revanche
qui est sur c durablement la situation
n'est pas tenable alors qu'est score une
fois comment la raison mais prenons
l'exemple moi j'ai pas de gouvernement
ce pas nous faire ça c'est au groupe et
au parti mais c'est vrai que quand on
est cadre d'un groupe politique ou d'un
parti politique on doit exprimer sa
position et elle fait sens pour
l'ensemble des militants pour l'ensemble
des élus on peut pas dire moi ce que je
veux faire c'est secret j'en ai rien vu
le secret rabaud rapportant général de
8o si vous voulez celui là ou un autre
mais en tout cas voilà donc qui a nous
il faut pour l'instant vraiment appeler
à l'esprit de responsabilité et montrer
ou dire à ceux et celles qui n'en font
pas preuve que benoît hamon il fait
preuve de maîtrise à vous savez il est
pas d'accord
personnellement je pense qu'il aurait pu
dû manifester autrement son désaccord
une abstention suffisait il votre compte
parce que je pense qu'il ya en effet un
congrès il a probablement des d'autres
penser que les simples pensée de dvd ou
de se différencier du gamin mais vous
n'êtes pas d'accord
encore une fois c'est pas tant les
désaccords et vous parliez tout à
l'heure il ya plusieurs gauches
évidemment on voit bien qu'au parti
socialiste
vous avez des gens qui considèrent de
mon point de vue à tort que la politique
qui est menée depuis dix ans une
politique d'austérité qui le disent urbi
et orbi
si je peux dire même si on plutôt laïque
bon nous ne le pensons pas nantes ont
fait plus de 4 % de déficit budgétaire
quand on a 50 7 % de dépenses publiques
du pib c'est pas dossier t il le pense
avec benoît gros congrès parce que
l'étape maintenance et saas et c'est le
congrès en juin c'est son problème à lui
oui c'est à lui de voir comment il va se
comporter ce qui veut demander aux
militants
de soutenir ses positions c'est à mon
avis probable où est ce que finalement
prenant en compte les conséquences de ce
qu'il a fait il se dit peut-être que
quand même il faut que je trouve des
manières plus policé de faire entendre
ma voix d'ange dispositif socialiste
essaie lui il faudrait inviter la
prochaine fois dans mes questions aussi
parce que le congrès il concerne tous
les socialistes vigilance
normalement oui est-ce qu'ils n'arrivent
pas peut-être un peu trop tôt ce congrès
parce qu'on va on va se focaliser
uniquement sur ces deux gauches et ça va
être un référendum pour ou contre
l'action des gouvernants bien écoutez
moi je pense qu'il arrive absolument bon
moment parce qu on parle beaucoup d'une
crise y compris qui divise
une partie des socialistes qui est la
crise économique et sociale
et là dessus il peut y avoir des
désaccords mais on a une seconde dont on
ne parle jamais qui vaut pour moi plus
importante aujourd'hui encore que la
crise économique et sociale c'est la
crise démocratique c'est le fait que les
français en ont marre du jeu politique
classique des postures des disputes des
angles là vous défendiez une sixième
république exactement j'ai vraiment
cette question démocratique le congrès
il doit mettre au premier rang des
préoccupations des socialistes au delà
même des réponses économiques et
sociales la façon de répondre à la crise
démocratique comment on fait pour que
les français fassent le boulot
christophe cambadélis se sentent à
nouveau représentée par ceux qui sont
censés diriger le peuple haïtien où
l'état où les parcs et ça c'est si ce
congrès pouvait au delà de pour contre
le gouvernement pour contre la politique
économique et sociale bon sens au nez
l'espèce de rappel général des troupes
on est au bord du gouffre à sa banque
les français ne votent plus quand il
vote la moitié d'entre eux votent front
national est ce qu'ils ont fait aux
chorales de nature à les rassurer peut
exactement il faut que le congrès soit
le congrès du ressaisissement dans
lattitude pour répondre à la crise
démocratique mois passés au jeudi vous
savez que quand il ya 49 droite qui
hystéro chaîne
en général c'est une motion de censure
elle a été défendue le jeudi par la
droite
mot censure défendue par la droite mais
aussi par une partie des élus
communistes le gouvernement évidemment
n'est pas tombé il n'y avait pas de
majorité pour cela
mais le débat était quand même très
agitée rim benameur l'avenir du
gouvernement valls débattu pendant deux
heures avec force
l'ump lui d y montent au créneau pour
défendre leur motion de censure
ils ne ménagent pas leur charge contre
le gouvernement
vous êtes à la tête d'une majorité
fragile relative qui vous oblige en
permanence à marchander pour ne pas dire
à boursicoter comme un président de
conseil sous la quatrième république
et n'est ce pas là finalement votre
marque de fabrique
celle d'un chef de gouvernement qui
chaque jour se coupent davantage de ses
troupes
l'opposition qui a trouvé un allié
inattendu dans l'hémicycle le front de
gauche pas les mêmes arguments
mais ici encore le gouvernement valls en
ligne de mire le moment est grave grave
pro-gouvernement d'abord et avant tout
pour le gouvernement il est vrai que ce
projet de loi symbolise à lui seule la
dérive libérale d'une majorité qui était
pourtant censé incarner une alternative
à la politique de sarkozy et bonnet la
guerre à la finance car la voie que vous
avez choisie est celle du reniement
permanent le projet de la macro n'en est
que la consécration
manuel valls clos le débat un discours
qui a tout du discours de politique
générale il met en avant l'unité
retrouvée de sa majorité je vous
remercie monsieur le président jacob
très chaleureusement
c'est vous de le rappeler par votre
initiative
aujourd'hui car elle est bienvenue elle
va faire la démonstration claire il n'y
a pas de majorité alternative
il n'y a qu'une seule majorité divers
certes mais une majorité élu par les
français
une majorité qui a entendu leur message
qui connaît leurs exigences
monsieur jacob respecter le choix du
peuple français
sans grande surprise la motion de
censure a été rejetée
c'est donc maintenant le sénat qui
s'emparera de la loi macro
finalement avec ses 49 3 vous avez donné
un grand bol d'air à la droite paul
sentiments humains qu il y a manqué des
voix j'ai surtout le sentiment que c'est
d'abord un fiasco
voilà pour la vie politique tout ça
c'est dans ce bocal qui était jeudi
l'assemblée nationale on a eu absolument
tout y compris l'ivresse des communistes
mais des communistes qui votent une
motion de censure présentée par l'ump
enfin plus personne n'y comprend rien
heureusement que tout ça les français
regardent ça avec un peu de détachement
ou même un bocal c'est à dire ça veut
dire quoi que la banque tout ce qui se
passe maintenant l'hémicycle mais tout
le monde s'en fiche
si bocal théâtre gesticulations loyer
c'est la vie politique mais moi je vous
dis que tout ça par rapport à la crise
démocratique qu'il ya dans ce pays
tous ceux qui participent de ce jeu là
rajoute des fractures à une société qui
n'en a pas besoin
rajoute de la distance entre les
français et la déplacement devient la
sixième république que vous avez de vous
en tout cas c'est le moment doit de
trouver les moyens de ressources et la
démocratie de revitaliser la démocratie
et je pense que ça demandera des
réformes et ceci est sociétale et
institutionnels real on aura
probablement l'occasion d'appareils dans
les scénarii semaine oui moi j'ai une
petite question aussi qu'il est capable
d'ouvrir un peu le débat vous avez vu
peut-être le changement de pied de
françois fillon
il est passé d'une line hi ha pourquoi
pas à voter la gauche en cas de duel fn
parti socialiste mais vous vous rendez
compte quand je vous dis que c'est pas
du tout ça c'est une mélasse comment
voulez vous que les français s'y
retrouve tout le monde prend les
positions pour en changer trois semaines
après ses sept illisible la société a
besoin de repères
elle a besoin de gens qui tiennent des
positions qu'ils réfléchissent avant de
les prendre qu'il ne prenne pas sous le
coup de la pression des circonstances
mais qui les prennent par conviction et
qui assument leurs responsabilités
quitte à être sanctionné nous le
gouvernement - modestement dans ce
gouvernement
j'assume totalement nos choix j'espère
qu'ils vont produire des résultats et je
prends la pleine responsabilité de ses
choix y compris aux risques de la
sanction demain si elle doit alors oui
c'est nommer ces girouettes absence de
convictions absence de ténacité absence
de point de repère il ya de la trahison
des clercs dans tout ça est leur
trahison des clercs au sens premier du
terme oui
quand un pays est en crise on doit
bon si on n'est pas capable de tenir bon
on revendique pas le leadership
politique qu'on soit de gauche ou qu'on
soit de droite il doit être à la hauteur
de responsabilité alors on va accueillir
à présent notre partenaire du figaro
pour un décryptage de l'actuel et la
loupe diskan et jim jara cédant la place
bonjour quatre avoue michael et vous
nous parler de françois hollande et de
l'article 49-3 tout à fait bonjour
thierry mandon on va en ouvrir ensemble
si vous le voulez bien la boîte archives
la première elle date de 2006 s'agit
d'une vidéo qui a beaucoup tourné sur
internet cette semaine c'est celle de
françois hollande au quat'sous quatre
colonnes de l'assemblée qui critiquent
le recours de dominique deville temps
aux 49 3 pour faire passer le cpe on
écoute le 49-3 est une brutalité le 49-3
est un déni de démocratie de 49,3 est
une manière de freiner d'empêcher le
débat parlementaire mais il va se
poursuivre ce débat parlementaire
d'une manière ou d'une autre alors vous
parliez il ya quelques minutes de crise
politique de crise démocratique et de
vieilles politiques
est ce que le 49-3 a encore sa place
dans un dispositif de politique moderne
que vous défendez parce que c'est pas la
vieille politique justement 49 francs ça
se réfléchit
vous avez raison sur le long sur le
moyen terme ça ça se réfléchit mais le
49 3 2 jeudi
mardi par dont les 40 notre hub de magie
c'est pas le même 49 3 2 jeudi il vient
après cinq semaines de débat le 49-3
2006 il vient avant même tout débat ya
jamais eu de débat sur le cpm le début
du débat au cpl av
et celui là celui de 2006 il a rien à
faire dans ma vie politique
celui qui à la fin de la fin quand un
texte a été adopté arctic parquet ce qui
est le cas de la voix mais kron et puis
qu'on découvre comme ça à la dernière
minute qu'il ya des gens qui partent en
vrille
excusez moi à gauche et à droite celui
là encore en 2008 le parti socialiste a
voulu réformer le 49-3 est-ce que c'est
toujours d'actualité aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit des socialistes il est réformé
puisque vous savez que son usage est
limité un texte par session
parlementaire
or les textes budgétaires est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin c'est
dit je pense que ça fait partie des
réflexions institutionnel nécessaire
mais il y en a plein d'autres et elles
vont faire marcher ensemble on enlève
pas c'est pas parce qu'on vient de 49,3
contre le tout au contraire mais en
revanche comment fabrique des lois de
meilleure qualité des débats
parlementaires plus vive des parties
prenantes qui peuvent participer à cette
fabrique de la loi il ya beaucoup de
sujets qui méritent une réflexion
j'aimerais aller sur une deuxième
archives oui tout à fait ça date de
novembre dernier c'était à public sénat
sur le plateau de preuve parfois vous
avez qualifié d'indispensable
l'organisation d'une primaire la plus
large possible
à gauche on vous écoute la primaire pour
moi elle est indispensable pour quelles
raisons pas pour faire du tir au pigeon
contre x ou y ou pour écarter quelques
voitures y compris celle du président
s'il réussissait son quinquennat qui
devrait se représenter
elle est indispensable parce que
particulièrement 2010 est ce que vous ne
réglez pas dans une primaire
vous le retrouvez au premier tour de la
présidentielle tout les problèmes de
configuration politique que vous n'avez
pas rêvé dans la primaire la plus large
possible y compris élargi vous les
retrouverez dans le premier tour de la
présidentielle ça veut dire que vous
diminuez les forces les capacités de la
gauche avec présente au deuxième tour de
la présidentielle alors à l'époque vous
aviez été un peu recadré par le porte
parole du gouvernement steffen hofmann
qui estimait que c'était pas vraiment le
moment d'aborder ce sujet est-ce que vos
propos sont toujours d'actualité
aujourd'hui après les attentats de
charlie hebdo et alors que la gauche
affiche un peu ses divisions grand jour
j'ai rien à rajouter à ce que j'ai dit
c'est li s'est dit d'accord donc pas que
ryan troisième archives jim tout à fait
il ya une troisième à celle là c'était
il ya un an vous n'étiez pas encore mini
vous étiez porte parole du groupe ps à
l'assemblée
et vous n'y étiez pas à critiquer le
gouvernement de jean marc ayrault en
filant la métaphore footballistique on a
perdu 2-0 le début de quinquennat c'est
un score très difficile à remonter
disiez-vous sur radio classique alors un
an plus tard où on est le tableau des
scores de zéro il ya un an aujourd'hui
on en est où
la deuxième mi-temps vient de commencer
on est à mi quinquennat et il faut
marquer très vite je peux un jour 2 0
comme il ya toujours 2 0 oui bien sûr ça
n'a pas changé on vient de reprendre la
deuxième mi temps
je pense que l'un d'eux 2015 c'est les
premières minutes de cette deuxième mi
temps il faut qu'on ait un peu de
reprise économique je pense qu'on en
aura il faut si possible qu'on ait un
peu de résultats sur le front du chômage
et des perspectives si on a ça on
revient un peu au score ça suffit pas
encore tout à fait assez mais c'est la
première étape donc on joue très gros
sur 2015 d'où la nécessité d'aller au
bout de démarche de réforme comme on l'a
fait s'est terminée sur une note
on termine sur notre 15 sur 20 c la note
que vous aviez attribué à manuel valls
lors de son premier discours de
politique générale on avait le dernier
aujourd'hui après une semaine compliquée
pour le prêt ministre quelle note vous
lui donnez aucun cas j'ai dit qu'à
sûrement je n'étais pas au gouvernement
maintenant c'est plus objectivement à
noter je serai pas objectif si je suis
obligé de dire 20 sur 20 donc dispensé
mois de notation s'il vous plaît c'est
ça la voilà vous savez on a beaucoup
parlé de loi économique on a beaucoup
parlé de sujets en lien avec les liens
économiques on va parler a plus de
sujets sociétaux il ya aussi des
problèmes dans votre camp sur ces sujets
là et notamment sur le sujet sur la fin
de vie c'est le débat arrive à
l'assemblée nationale à peu près du mois
de mars
un débat avait lieu cette fois au sénat
on voit ça tout de suite
avec ses 6 ou une salle comble et une
émotion palpable
dix ans après la loi leoni qui sont
auteurs revient avec un nouveau texte
son objectif donner plus de droits aux
patients en fin de vie
nous savons que
lorsque les personnes en fin de vie
quelques fois et ce n'est pas
exceptionnel
on n'arrive pas à calmer leur souffrance
physique ou psychique
on peut à ce moment là les endormir pour
qu'elles puissent dormir pour ne pas
souffrir avant de mourir et c'est donc
la sédation profonde
la sédation profonde un droit pour finir
ses jours sans souffrir quand plus rien
n'est possible
ça se fait véritablement quand il n'y a
pas d'autre solution
et quand plusieurs médecins s'étant
réuni constate que de toute façon il
n'ya plus rien à faire qu'à attendre la
mort alors pour attendre la mort en
souffrent autant attendre la mort
paisiblement
l'autre proposition de la loi ce sont
les directives anticipées des
instructions laissées par le patient à
ses proches au corps médical ou dans une
lettre sur ses volontés au cas où il est
condamné à mourir
le texte prévoit de les rendre
inamovible il ya effectivement tout un
débat pour savoir si nous avons la
capacité de dire ce que nous voudrions
dans des circonstances que nous ne
connaissons pas que dont nous n'avons
pas l'expérience mais ce que nous
voudrions à la fin de notre vie si nous
sommes atteints d'une maladie très grave
la loi sera discutée à l'assemblée
nationale le 10 mars prochain et devrait
arriver au sénat dès le mois de juin
plus vite que prévu gérard larcher le
président du sénat lui-même très investi
sur le sujet il tient beaucoup
quand je vous disais qu'il ya des lignes
de fracture au sein de votre parti ce
qui à 85 députés socialistes qui en
commission ont voulu aller beaucoup plus
loin que ce qui était inscrit dans la
loi à savoir une aide médicale active à
mourir c'était
à l'époque de l'engagement de françois
hollande l'engagement numéro 21 mais là
c'est que ce soit sur le niveau
économique au niveau sociétal
bien qu'elle de gauche encore je pas sûr
qu'il vous faille
oui d'abord vous avez raison il ya des
parlementaires qui veulent aller plus
loin de gauche mais il ya peut-être
aussi de droite sur ces sujets là là là
la scène politique classique la gauche
la droite ça marche pas forcément tu es
jean louis touraine qui a proposé à
manger les feuilles dont il ya désormais
le dès le ce débat existe dans la
société il existe dans nos rangs il
existe dans l'ensemble de l'échiquier
politique
est ce qu'il faut aller je crois que le
président de la république a été sage de
proposer la démarche la plus
consensuelle possible
ce câble des sujets extrêmement grave
très lourd et difficile le consensus
pas forcément cette loi va permettre
d'aller un peu plus loin que les
stipulations existantes
elle a été précédée par une mission
d'alain claeys monsieur leonetti qui ont
rencontré énormément de françaises et
français de situation est globalement
elles sont de meilleure qualité
répondent à plus de préoccupations
humaines que précédemment je pense qu'il
faut pas brusquer les choses ont pensé
que c'était nécessaire de légiférer à
nouveau sur ce sujet marc l'objet aussi
sensible et passe derrière des balles
cas qui ne rentrent pas dans la nuit il
y avait des affaires il y avait des
vraies incertitudes jolie pas à la
question de la volonté exprimée par les
malades qui allait mourir n'était pas
reconnu qu'un règlement on se comprenait
ou pas en compte la volonté exprimée du
malade avant même qu'ils soient en
situation de 2 dans laquelle on puisse
douter de cette volonté donc ça c'était
très important de 2,2 que le droit
évolue pour comprendre en compte cette
réalité là mais dans la rue encore une
fois ça va réveiller les passions vous
savez très bien je suis pas sûr je peux
le sentiment d'ailleurs que ça c'est
plus des patients sur l'échiquier
politique sur des jantes rays initiés
que dans la rue pour l'instant le texte
a été avec des poteaux chasser sur la
famille ce qui se passe ouais mais yen
il y avait une demande quand même de la
société de préciser un certain nombre de
deux points qu'ils le seront par cet
extrait de love crois pas que ce sera au
contraire un grand déchirement nationale
mais un dc3 fatalement à des bas c'est
normal mais bien sûr mais le débat
politique
c'est très bien faut pas là la nouvelle
politique c'est pas une politique où
tout le monde pense la même gêne donc
liberté de ces sciences c'est la thune
vote au sein et notamment des biens
sociaux mais mais c'est ce que je vous
dis je pense même mois que le problème
du bocal aujourd'hui c'est quelle
nouvelle politique qui est maire quand
vous dites le bocal vous faites
référence à ce jeu à certains moments de
la vie du parlement pas tous ça nous
finalement on a l'impression que ce qui
se discute ne compte plus la seule chose
qui compte c'est les positionnements
politiques et partisans et un peu
pavlovien d'une classe politique sur les
sujets mois pour moi ça c'est le bocal
le bocal
c'est un final peut se passer n'importe
quoi là nous on est dans l'opposition
donc on se presse pas dit s'ils peuvent
ou non moi c'est passé la conception que
j'ai de la bri à bâle à la politique
c'est au défender conviction pour les
français et on peut tout à fait en
désaccord mais en défense et conditions
pour les français on ne défend pas des
intérêts politiciens c'est comme ça je
compte sur les choses et le tout c'est
de sortir du blocage
merci beaucoup thierry mandon d'avoir
été notre invité on voulait se retourner
à vos dossiers très lourds et très
chargé et non se retrouve la semaine
prochaine bonne semaine à tous au revoir